good morning everyone so why don't we
get started welcome to another BD gk
guard to the fundamental seminar i am
alex buco directors of the egk centers
Coordination Center at UCLA and so this
morning we have Professor Michael
Mahoney with us Michael is at UC
Berkeley my alma mater and he's in the
department of statistics and a member of
the international computer science
institute he's recognized for his work
with big data particularly focusing on
the statistical and algorithmic issues
surrounding large-scale data analyses
you may know him through his leadership
and involvement in different arenas
including running the biennial workshop
on algorithms for modern massive data
sets and the NSF tripod foundation of
data analysis Institute at Cal today
Michael will be talking to us about some
of the more foundational issues
surrounding data and its analysis and
its relation to biomedicine
Michael it's great to have you with us
this morning and I know we're all
looking forward to hearing more about
this and your perspective and so why
don't you take it from there
good thanks and just a check you can
hear me and you can see me flip between
the first two slides yeah okay good
so it's great to be here although here
is that the at the office as usual but
it's great to be here virtually and have
the chance to to talk with you and so
what's hidden so this was page one and I
put a question mark at the end of the
title I don't know if that was in the
email I sent her if that was cut off by
you guys or me but what I wanted was ask
a question you know what does
biomedicine have to say about the
foundations of data and vice versa and
I'll say what I mean by that and I want
to give a perspective that might be not
immediately obvious from this slide to
that was the sort of brief fire that was
run through so I'm in statistics and I
sitting in computer science in a in the
rise lab which is in you know build
large-scale stuff in computer science a
lot of the work sort of is you know the
flavor of applied math and so sitting
sort of between those three areas and so
in a sense that if there is such a thing
as foundations
data presumably it's at something at the
interface of those areas but I've
actually never taken a class in in
statistics or computer science and so
that's good and bad it's bad because you
know you there's certain blind spots you
have it's good on the other hand because
it means you sort of ask different
questions so my background actually was
in chemical physics and genetics and
biophysics and so I learned that using
what you can do by not knowing certain
things but I was working at NIH as a
summer intern and I didn't owe any
genetics I was picking it up on the side
and literally doing what lab works so I
you know I'd be doing pipetting and
we're looking at DNA looping as a
mechanism gene regulation and then a
little bit of modeling off site lattice
models of proteins and protein folding
and then molecular dynamics and Monte
Carlo sort of simulations and so in that
sense you know really sort of in the
weeds on on certain application areas
and as I finished the dissertation you
know looked around and saw that you know
this is in 2000 your large data seems to
be an important thing and of course now
it's 18 years later and that word means
very different things but and so I
thought what I do is maybe you know from
the perspective of someone that's seen
you know I'm an immigrant right I mean
the move from area a to area B and is
now looking back on how the two areas
fit together maybe talk about
foundations of data and and now there's
you know big data and massive data and
data science is all these buzzwords and
it's achieving a certain level of
maturity I mean it Berkeley has a new
data science division so this is not
like bioinformatics from you know the
90s or so where or nanotechnology which
is of interest but you know to a small
group of constituency I mean this data
science division is being created at
Berkeley because you know basically
every department thinks the data science
has something to say about it and this
is not just math and computer science
and and physics and and computational
biology this is history you know the
social sciences and this is you know
economics with quantitative stuff and
this is ancient history you know the
cuneiform digital library sort of thing
so it's the sort of thing that touches a
wide wide range of people
it's very broad and it's one Aryan the
questions can we distill out the
foundations of data and so one of the
things they're trying to do with tripods
which is an NSF program that we created
you know because NSF you know funds in
certain silos you know can we create
them and roughly what they were computer
science and math and stats and domains
can we create a program that
deliberately tries to cut across that
and create foundations more generalize
so so the context for tripods is that it
was a specific call designed to create
Institute's for foundations of data and
and what's an institute you know I don't
know you tell me I mean so the community
is trying to decide that so this 12
phase 1 Institute's there'll be three or
four phase 2 Institute's and you know
what's what's an institute which
foundations of data you know I don't
know you tell me so there's something
that the community's working through and
so I thought I'd share some thoughts on
on what biomedicine has to say about
this I think it could but I think it
could also not and so it's is sort of a
bifurcation point in history and to my
mind it'll be a little unfortunate if
the answer is not but this do you know
the fields of all of in different ways
and so I think there's an opportunity
here one not just to sort of use data
science and data but you know to also
influence how people think about it
because this is a big trend in society
and and the problems the questions the
types of data that you get in genetics
and in biophysics and in molecular
biology and in medical imaging and
arranging areas like that it is very
different than you get on on Twitter
feed data and social networking at
Facebook and internet advertising and so
on and so you know tamama it would be
nice if domains we have a lot of
infrastructure knowledge help to address
foundation so this is the question I
have all right so insiders versus
outsider's view so so a question just
and I've partly set the stage already
but the question sort of you know in
maybe this seminar series you know
what's the difference between genetics
and molecular biology you know and
biochemistry and biophysics right so I
said in my dissertations in Chemical
Physics that's different in physical
chemistry and you know how is it
different so that we level details with
why they're so what's the difference
mean
genetics and molecular biology and
biophysics and biochemistry and the
answer you know is really not much
they're about the same and they're about
the same in particular if you're a
methods person and by methods person I
mean someone you know who
self-identifies is doing methods data
analysis or machine learning or
statistics or theory of algorithms or
artificial intelligence whatever you say
I do X or X's statistics or machine
learning or artificial intelligence and
from that perspective the other all this
biology they're different than internet
and social media you get the data from
one of those areas you probably ignored
its important domain details and that's
been cleaned up for you by someone else
and your goal is to evaluate your new
method so in the same way as in you know
any area in biomedicine or whatever you
have a new method you have a new tool
you have a new result in you want to see
how it fits and other things if your
methods person you develop methods and
I'll say a little bit more about what
that means it's more than a software I
mean the way that instantiates itself
often times in biology is software but
that's that's an implementation of the
method and your reviewers evaluate you
and when you send a proposal to and NIH
doesn't really do it so if you've done
it NSF or DOA or wherever they evaluate
on the methods and the data and the the
the the science is very very much
secondary and so that's maybe a surprise
maybe not but you know there's no
difference they're about the same so to
ask the question instead of the flip
side you're if you're someone who thinks
about biomedicine and any one of those
areas and you know that there's a very
you know fine granularity between
genetics and bio physics of molecular
biology they're very different histories
and so if you're someone who knows that
your question what's the difference
between data analysis and machine
learning and statistics and artificial
intelligence and you know scientific
computing and computational math and
databases and so on so it's the
difference here and the answer is you
know not much I mean they're all about
the same right if you're a science
person and and by that I mean you know
they're all just tools they're all just
hammers and you get the tool from any
one of those areas and you write the
paper to say your science results and
you bury the
details in a method section and as you
know method sections are usually in ten
points rather than twelve point font or
whatever at the last page of the paper
meaning it you know people are be
encouraged not to read it right so so
they're very very much secondary they're
buried in a method section no one wants
to read and the reviewers evaluated
based on the science and if the results
not sort of robust to different methods
you know that's not good science but you
know which has a side effect that the
details of the methods can't be so so
important and so if you're a science
person say you self-identify as doing
genetics I'm lucky my biology only
deserve as we talked about before so
this I think is the you know inside
averse outside of you and and I think
understanding the landscape of
foundations and also how biomedicine
sort of fits into that you know it's
important so I'm still looking for
better quote this one was in The New
York Times I guess it's about six years
ago by now so there was then it was big
date and now it's a little involved a
little bit in the buzzword is data
science and so on but what is this big
data thing and there's a lot of buzz and
hype and so that's just take that for
granted it's certainly a meme and a
marketing term and and there's a lot of
businesses who say I want big data to
solve my problems and not don't know
what that means
so get beyond that essentially you know
I think it's it's sort of a shorthand
for you know basically trends in
technology you know measurement devices
computer chip design and so on that
basically opens the door for new
approaches to understanding the world
and making decisions and so that
decision could be in the scientific
context and I and so you know why are
big data big and why are they there's
these the velocity and veracity and so
on you know why are they big and so on
and you know why do they have high
velocity I mean the reason is it you're
generating data at more times and more
places and at more you know resolutions
and so a factor of ten more data isn't
just more data it's different data
that's a key you know a key thing of
course and so big is sort of a red
herring and so I think it's not a bad
thing that it evolved to be data science
and remove the big because big data is
one word it's not big as an adjective
modifying data because big data means
big means different things to different
people for some people you know you're
really large you're
that's raw number of bits as terabytes
or petabytes and for some people you
know you you're working with snips and
you have and you have you know hapmap I
think originally what we didn't have
then this was 2006 but it had 400 people
by forget what the number of snips was
you know and a hundred thousand snips or
whatever was right and so that's large
by some senses you know you want to call
some code in now Python but maybe you
are but MATLAB whatever you know the
software package uses you know that's
large enough that might you know take a
little bit of effort so in either case
there's sort of memory management issues
and it's just hard to answer very basic
questions what the data looks like right
I mean whether you're extremely large it
is moderately large and and it's
important understand I mean what does a
kind of I mean use these numbers and so
this this is a few years old so the
exact numbers are quite a little bit
stale but I mean imagine you were to
watch 20 years of movies you 24/7 you
sit in front of your computer screen you
watch movies or listen to 20,000 years
of audio so that's a petabyte right so I
mean literally you can't evaluate a
little you can't look at it and and and
so a lot of the data you know analysis
sort of methods on the method side is
about coming up with tools to
interrogate the data act that's scaled
it literally you can't you know evaluate
and so I think it's really you should
think about it as the modern version of
the telescope and as you know probably
you get a telescope you get a microscope
you get an electron microscope you get
x-ray diffraction technology get MRI
technology every time you have a new
technology like this it opens the door
for all sorts of fundamental advances
and and the reason basically is that you
see things that you can't see before you
and and that could be fine grained
movements of molecules it could be stars
on the other side of the universe
or it could be you know fine great
movement of people I mean if you have
something in your cell phone I mean you
know there's a large internet company
depending on what phone I own that knows
that I'm sitting here at a given spot
and I'm not walking down the street
because my phone is stationary right now
on the desk and the resolution is pretty
good I don't know what it is it's ten
feet or something and so like I can be
tracked someone knows that right now
fine scale clicks on what you by
tracking the packages you know fine fine
scale measurements of temperature and
chemicals I was involved in
about two or three years ago on mass
spec imaging and I had known this from
graduate school I thought this was some
one of these very old school things you
know from 50 years ago and I come to
find out that they can get incredibly
fine measurements of large large
molecules and so they had we were
working not something on something just
a little bit shy of the terabyte scale
in terms of a very fine resolution and
it was amazing I mean you can measure
resolution that you just couldn't
measure before and when you do that easy
things become hard and hard things
become easy right on so on the methods
side you know well on the appliance I
know it's easier to see the other side
of the universe you know ten billion
light years away than it is to see a few
miles or a few thousand miles you know
to the bottom of the ocean and on the
method side you know certain types of
computations you might want to do means
and medians and sums are just very easy
when you're at that scale so that when
you're when you're at small data and how
do you do that with very very large data
that can be a real challenge and so one
of the things we'll get back to later is
certain sorts of computations doing at
very large scales and what we need to
worry about is very sort of mundane
stuff like that because easy things
become hard and hard things become easy
so I hope by now the elephant in the
room here is that so I mean I wandered
between a couple different areas and I'm
at the center of all this sort of
foundations of data in some ways and at
least in my experience when people talk
about large-scale data you know
typically it it reveals more about them
and their biases and their background
and training and the way they think
about it then about the data itself
right and so if you're a machine learner
you so really is like he's blind man
that with the elephant the elephant your
machine smooth a need to do
regularization and if you're a
statistician you might say you know I
need to just start with a model before
anything else and if you're a high
performance computing person you just
say wow I need a bigger machine and if
you're in computer science person you
just say I need fast algorithms and if
you're a data scientist you know you
just say data is a mess and the hard
part is is cleaning it up and so I just
need to clean it up and of course know
we're here is there anything about
downstream use cases I could have a
whole mother plot on different ways
people ask questions depending on you
know this is this I originally develop a
slide for more methods
you can imagine a whole other set of
questions people who use it in different
ways
and generate it in different ways and
store in different ways so of course
it's you know do something out of
foundations of data there's a great
opportunity here just to sort of
understand the world in which we live
and very foundational things from
scientific questions but also
engineering questions how to control
these things and I think it gets beyond
you know it requires going beyond this
situation where you have the blind man
and the elephant to where you know you
at least take one eye patch off or you
know you get a little bit better sense
of the data quad data and so which
basically trying to do that and so I'm
gonna have a couple examples a little
bit later but of ways in which we and
others tried to do that but you know if
you think about the blind man I think
there's there's there's one ISM there's
many many ways to be different but I
think the sort of lead the leading order
bit as it were the lead access of
variants if you were if you know what
PCA and SVD are is that you you're
either think about it let's say like a
computer scientist and so this is a
little less true now than it was 10 or
certainly 20 years ago just because
there is revolving but by computer
scientists I mean someone who was you
know trained in a computer science
department for them the data really are
a record of everything there is you know
and so you think purchases at Walmart
that's a canonical example and the goal
is to find to process the data to find
interesting patterns in the data and
associations and heavy hitters and
there's this you know this sort of toy
proverbial example the beer diapers
paradox and I don't know if it's true or
not but 90 mid-90s you know someone in
anything-goes kdd and ACMs data analysis
venue
you know the idea is that you know you
notices associate this is this
correlation between buying beer and
buying diapers at a certain time of day
you know at Kmart Wal Mart or something
and so why is that you know what does
maybe maybe you know the hypothesis is
babies need beer and they also need
diapers and so you in
so you buy them at the same time and if
you know about the domain you say well
that's probably not the case but maybe
there's something else maybe someone's
coming home from work and his ass you
know you got a boat go buy diapers
because they're running out of diapers
and the person goes through this and
then of course at the end of the aisle
there's a beer being sold on sale and so
why don't I pick some up while I'm at it
and so whether this is true or false it
yeah this particular proverbial example
historically sort of it illustrates the
point but I just want to find patterns
in the data and finding those patterns
can be very tricky and so the goal is to
develop approximation algorithms under
different models of data access now if
you're computing things that are
manifestly not useful that's not so good
but any downstream use is is very much
secondary right the question about why
you have this pattern is very much
secondary and and so I just want to
compute stuff so the data sitting in
front of you is all there is a very
different perspective and this is
formalized in academic departments and
statistics departments but basically you
know everyone else natural scientists
social scientists everyone else thinks
this way and for them the data are and
in particular biomedicine ideas so so
the data are a particular random
instantiation of some underlying process
going on in the world and the goal is to
extract information about the world and
the data are holy because they're the
only insight you have into the world
everything else is just stories right
and so you want to make entrances in
particular about unseen events by
positing some sort of model and
describing random variability around the
deterministic model of some sort and
this is important because the people who
build large-scale systems think about
the data one way and everyone who uses
data thinks about the date of a very
very different way there's a real clash
here so in the latter case computation
very much is secondary and in the and in
the data is primary and in the first
case vice versa so these are very
different paradigms and so in particular
statistics Natural Science the
scientific computing problems involve
computation but the computation per se
in and of itself is very much secondary
and and in particular that means that it
makes only make sense to develop
algorithms for well posed problems and
so you know to be slightly technical a
well posed problem if you know like an
integral equation or something I mean
it's
a problem where the solution exists it's
unique and it's robust with respect to
variations in the input data and you
might say it doesn't make sense to solve
problems the solution of which doesn't
exist or isn't unique or is is widely
dependent on input data so we'll get to
that in a second but first you know
write down a model and think about
computation later and so that's that's
the way most users of data think about
it and and this is true more generally
than the foundations but we know in
particular spective foundations and in
computer science if you adopt that
perspective it's just much much easier
to study computation per se in discrete
settings so if you're familiar with
Turing machines and logic and complexity
classes so numerical analysis was part
of computer science in the early days
and it was largely pushed out you know
as to be computational science to
different domains and so I think there's
a question about data science and how
does it evolve going forward is it more
like computer science or computational
science or coalesces or just sort of
infects over a lot of different domains
and so that's a question for the future
but you know if you're studying
computation per se the theory of
algorithms really divorces computation
from the data it's a statement about
functional transformations and so on so
if you know NP completeness and
approximation algorithms and these sort
of reductions these are statement about
computations independent of data and so
you know what's an example of a not well
posed problem that people think about
you might say well it doesn't make sense
to even think about it it doesn't vary
continuously with the data and it's not
unique and so on and the answer is you
know basically any problem that people
think about when they talk about MP
completeness or approximation of them
and those are not well posed you change
one edge or something and then a graph
or you change one role in a database and
something changes widely so you know
basically any problem like that as a
sort of a more practical matter you're
not going to be happy if you go to the
bank and your bank account has you know
one hundred two thousand dollars three
hundred two thousand three hundred
twelve dollars and seventeen cents and I
write you a check for $100 and you
deposit at the bank and the bank says
you know the data sort of noisy in the
world's messy why don't we just round
this off to particular round it down to
the closest one significant digit or two
significant digits right and so the bank
can handle and so the least significant
digit of your bank counts not a
particularly well posting or a robust
thing
in an inferential sense but it's an
obviously extremely important thing and
so a database system you know and you
can deposit a check on the other side of
the world and see the answer in your
bank in a matter of seconds and so a lot
of the infrastructure that's built up to
do computation assumes one thing where's
the people using it is assuming another
so I wanted to give you sort of three
anecdotes and then I'll go into a little
bit more detail on this first one but
three anecdotes as to you know just
things that we've done in the past that
I think tap into this general challenge
and the idea is to develop sort of very
some let's say foundational a
theoretically principled stuff meaning
stuff that would be interesting to a
person who's a theorist who doesn't care
about practical stuff but also motivated
by very practical very particular data
challenges and and have them apply to
those to those areas and so on is I'll
say randomized linear algebra a
randomized matrix algorithms so if you
if you are you know running any sort of
computation I mean it is a hello world
example think principal components
analysis or factor analysis but there's
many many things that's boiled down to
this so randomized linear Allen was an
area that uses randomization to just do
very basic matrix computations and you
typically want to speed them up meaning
it's a running time claim because it's
grew up within computer science
theoretical computer science but you
might want to make statistical camp
claims in particular cuz there's gonna
be randomness inside the algorithms it's
not gonna be randomness in the data you
can use random this is a computational
resource and so on this on this on the
on the methodological side that you know
there's connections with theoretical
computer science and areas of math like
convex analysis Johnson limited Strasse
you know without that's something having
to do with random projections and and
isometry xin hilbert spaces and Banach
spaces you tended to get additive error
algorithms if you're computer scientist
you know what that is if you don't know
if you're not a computer science you
don't know the difference being that in
relative error algos probably you got
good worst-case guarantees but there's
no statistical analysis no
implementations so when I got into this
game and basically every one of those is
now sort of this gap has been bridge so
you know fast forward ten years later
there's been applications in nla as
numerical linear algebra meaning if you
call code you call Python you call
whatever it calls something it's calling
la path under the hood and so this is
something that you know applied
mathematician has developed over the
years and so and so machine learning
statistics a whole bunch of areas of
data analysis in particular genetics
I'll give you an example of that in a
little bit you can get faster algorithms
relative error numerically stable good
statistical properties and in particular
the LA Pact is the sort of state of the
art software and it's actually sort of
remarkable when you can get a method
there class of methods that are sort of
theoretically rich as these that I sort
of allude to on the left that beats la
pack and parallel and distributed
implementations on terabytes of data and
so you that you could actually bridge
that gap so you have methods and in a
sense these methods you know get an a-
by the perspective of theoretical
computer science or statistics or
machine learning or scientific computing
or whatever but you know in most methods
will get an a by winning any one of
those metrics on a d- by the others and
so it's hard to satisfy two or three
different constraints but in terms of
distilling out the foundations of data
that's that's you know what you might
need to do and so the question is how to
you bridge that gap and so technically
we had to decouple the randomization
from the linear algebra and they it
highlighted the importance of something
called the statistical leverage scores
so the only point to that is that this
stuff grew out of computer science the
one worldview and then order to bridge
the gap and on the one hand to get
better results by the computer science
metric and on the other hand give better
results by the statistics and the
genetics and all these other metrics we
had to take advantage of a statistical
notion that was buried under the hood
and so this is an example where you know
you do you're trying to use a
statistical idea of buried inside an
analysis to push forward a foundational
question that then then has a useful
downstream application and genetics say
so that's one example a not scientific
one is you know it's something that
we've done on social networks but a
similar results will hold for range of
genetic genes sort of networks and what
the results they're a little bit more
complicated so people imagine
in their mind just intuitively the high
dimensional spaces are sort of like
lower dimensional spaces but just with
more subscripts and nothing could be
further from the truth and so when
people think of a network so you can
think of a gene Network for 50,000 genes
is some sort of interaction structure
and you can say how is that similar and
different to the network or graph I
would create from links on a social
network like Facebook or from who clicks
on one on on Google or something
and so people think networks look like
on the left and when I say what they
think sometimes people explicitly think
that they put that in the paper other
times just all the tools they use assume
this you know and so you might you might
say this isn't what they look like but
if all the tools you use secretly assume
that the data are nice like that and
fail one of they're not nice you know
you're sort of implicitly assuming it
whereas in fact the networks look like
something in the middle and so the
question we were asking was can you
answer the question are there good
clusters in this million node graph and
how would you even answer that because a
million node graph is a size that it's
actually a little bit hard to work with
not terribly hard but a little bit hard
you could say I want to posit a null
model but the null models that in
existence are sort of so bad they're so
far from the truth that you know
answering the question with us back to
that null model doesn't say much because
the null models in such weak models and
so essentially we had to do is ask use
approximation algorithms expect to all
of those flaws a range of sort of things
that methods people like to poke and
prod at this data set you know and so we
imagine this isn't like bottom of the
ocean or the other side of the universe
or or you know protein structures I'm
fine on the low granularity we can't
view it but we can poke and tear this
apart at it using these algorithmic
tools not being interested in in the the
structural results of the modeling
result of the lower bound results in and
of itself which is what most people to
ask but instead to to say I wanted a to
use these and the artifacts of what I
see to answer a question about the the
networks and the short answer is there
are no good clusters in these things
sometimes there's bad clusters that
aren't extremely bad and those actually
are very important in practice and so
that's the three-minute version of a
three hour talk you can find all
over online but I mean that's that's
that's to answer that question takes a
lot of effort that's like saying
proteins are you know they have the
alpha helixes and beta sheets and here's
a picture but to actually construct that
picture takes years of effort so this is
the sort of thing that we're doing here
and and this is this was a negative
result in a sense we're answering you
know there's not good structure and it's
hard to you know push on a negative
result even if it sort of a valuable
thing and the third thing is the third
anecdote is something called
regularization and I remember way back
when I was doing molecular modeling and
I read a review on how you may not want
to when you're doing x-ray
crystallography or a refinement you may
not want to get the exact minimum of you
so using molecular dynamics to refine
the parameters of the model you may not
want to get exactly the right parameters
you know that optimize the penalty and
you know you might want to only
approximately optimize it so you have a
temperature for em but it only
approximately optimize it and why would
you not want to exactly optimize it and
the answer is you might be fitting to
the peculiarities of the measurement or
of the particular model or something and
if you only approximate approximate
authorising you're more robust so this
is you know a very ubiquitous thing and
statistical data analysis called
regularization and typically people you
know impose regularization
explicitly you know just by optimizing
what I have on the left f plus lambda G
where F is some function and G is a
regularization term but a lot of the
approximation algorithms you do
implicitly regularize so if you imagine
you have a code that's doing some some
something on your sniff data what if you
just truncate small entries to zero
because it's convenient well what if you
don't you know you're doing an iterative
algorithm and you don't do a thousand
steps you only do three steps and what
if you've been the data in one way or
another so these are all design
decisions
and you know early stopped iterative
algorithms are approximation algorithms
they're also solving regularizing
versions of the original algorithms and
so some people would ask the one
question some people ask the other
question and bridging that gap is
interesting for a range of range of
reasons and and this is not this is this
is the way
described it here it sounds a little
theoretical but if anyone has heard of
neural networks say neural networks are
a mess from a practical and
methodological perspective because they
they convolve several different ideas
having to do with systems and
optimization and regularization and and
sort of in in the most pathological way
you can do you know they make a lot of
design decisions that are presented as
computational decisions but are really
regulation decision so it's just very
hard to understand what's going on so
you know this is a foundational question
but as very practical effects and sudden
you know there's a lot of dead that's
that's a getting a lot of interest in
machine learning on the method side and
you know I see I have something sitting
over on the corner of the desk here on
neural networks and genetics and you say
is this interesting and what's going on
here and why is it going on because it's
a very funny methodological algorithm
and it may be useful there of course it
may be useful just cuz it has lots of
knobs and and so now you're not P
hacking your model hacking because every
value of those knobs essentially
corresponds to a different model right
and so if I don't have a well-defined
objective its guiding what I'm doing you
run the risk of course sometimes you
can't but you know you run the risk of
testing out 50 models and only
publishing the best results and so
that's that's P hacking right there
that's model hacking you you you you
know if you have lots and lots of
parameters and you you know you test 50
models and one works and the other 49
don't if you don't publish all 50
results
you know you're you're engaged in some
sort of model hacking and so you may get
a good answer
for the particular data set you have but
does that port to a slightly different
data set you know it works on snips is
it gonna work on microwaves is it gonna
work on something very differently brain
images or is it something very very
different like internet data so you know
the foundational question there is a
challenging one because you're you're
cooking those decisions into the into
the pipeline and so that's hard to do so
company we could have spent an hour on
each of those if this was a more methods
audience and so I think the lessons here
are we're being forced to engineer a
union between very very different world
views which I've sort of caricatured as
computer scientific perspective versus
statistical perspective you know
computer science people versus everyone
else in the world adopt and there's a
lot of new force
functions generating lots of valuable
data that's forcing us to revisit these
old methods in a new light
often reinventing but but that's that's
good and so you know being getting an
a-minus by a metric that was relevant a
generation ago might not be so bad if
you can get an a-minus from four of
those metrics because this is where the
area is heading and so the last ball
given the existing forcing functions and
discipline area I think that many
methods and approaches are undervalued
for what non foundational people want
would want it would be good not to lose
them so what I mean by this if your
methods person it's much much easier to
work on Twitter data than it is on
genetics data or any astronomical data
or mass spec imaging data because a lot
of internet and social media data it's a
you know you're much more ignorant about
how the processes the data is generated
which places a lot more value on the
methods per se and so then there's a
selection bias towards working on data
that you know less about which means
that if you're developing a foundations
of data then you're developing a
foundations of data where I know very
little about where the data comes from
and it's not that you can't see how it
applies to that excited but if the
genesis want to you know get a genetics
result and aren't particularly
interested in how the method would apply
to say cosmology aren't indignation have
a method would apply to mass spec
imaging of climate science it's going to
become very siloed and so foundations is
gonna be a you know if you texana my's
the world into data applications we can
know a lot about des that where the data
come from loosely scientific maybe and
applications we don't know much all the
data comes from internet and social
media the sort of the the default is to
slide into into the one where you know
less less about it and and that's not
just because it's methods people are
lazy and it's easier to do that you know
new biomedical people meet them halfway
can i as a methods person and maybe you
know I'm a peculiar methods person and I
worked at NIH and I sort of if I have an
interest in this stuff so what I'm
asking this question I'm not asking me
I'm asking me as a methods person can I
go to NIH and get funding to work on
methods that may be indirectly relevant
for biomedical data
and the answer is is sort of no right I
mean it needs to be very closely tied to
something by medical and so you know I
say why do I do it I can go to NSF I can
go to a lot of other areas and get funds
and then then I bifurcate never talk
tonight so I mean I maybe I happen to
work there in the past personally but I
think it's a problem for the area and
it's not good for foundations but the
flip side is you know I think a lot of
scientific applications are much weaker
in terms of their interactions with A to
B as a result so two questions what you
know can we bridge these gaps and then
try between the different world views
and maybe engineer something you know
that's gonna point to the future in the
past and I think another is you know
most relevant days what if anything does
biomedicine have to offer right I mean
biomedicine and the foundations of data
so so here's an application of human
genetics the particulars else I'll show
you are a little bit old but we've
extended them in various ways and so I'm
willing to touch base afterwards if
anyone's interested in details but you
know snip data as most of you probably
know better than me I mean it's it's the
most common type of genetic variation
and then the genome is a bunch of types
of polymorphic variation and they're
known the single base pairs where some
non-negligible fraction of the
population has one of two you know one
or two nucleotides so I've laid it out
as individuals by snips and if your
methods person it's very convenient
though this looks almost like a matrix
and so you know now it's not hundreds by
thousands it's it's it's tens of
thousands so maybe hundreds of thousands
by millions and so you getting to the
point where you're get to be moderately
large so you have two parents and you
have a C or a T and it's it's a specific
locus where you have one of two
alternative alleles so you have either
CTP or a cc or a TT and so if you're
just in cold this is a 1 2 or 3 or 0
negative 1 plus 1 depending on whether
they're heterozygous or homozygous for
the minor or a major allele you know
mean Center so we've done that properly
if your methods person they can be a
little bit subtle actually because you
know the way you might met prepare stuff
in one area can be a little bit
different than other areas but let's say
we've done that properly and we have
because we've talked to both the methods
people and the and the geneticist and so
then you know you get a numeric matrix
and numeric matrix means you're in the
land of linear algebra and linear
algebra is the underlies a lot of
machine learning tools and so on and so
for
methods person you skip the previous
slides you're gonna skip the next couple
of slides just gonna have this matrix of
numbers and you're gonna apply a method
that would work on this matrix of
numbers and and any other matrix of
numbers and you don't ask where this
came from and so and so the motivation
here is one of two things and and again
as probably many of you know more than
me I mean there's no the human genome
everyone has it has different types of
variations each snip is sort of a
singular event in human history and so
you can do a couple different things you
can look at population history and Out
of Africa hypothesis this sort of thing
you can ask about personalized medicine
and so all of those are interesting the
last line here if your methods person
and cares only secondarily about those
and didn't you know work on this you
know way back when and you know as an
undergraduate but you care secondarily
it's it's a great application to mine
domain to stress novel methods because
we were actually came to this and we're
doing the scalable randomized linear
algebra and we're trying to so I was
trying to apply it back to microarray
data and this was I don't know two
thousand two three four timeframe and
microwaves are just a mess and we
couldn't get any regional results I knew
enough genetics I know enough methods
and it was a little disappointing and
then a few years later snip technology
developed it is much more amenable to
these techniques and so and so in that
sense it's a great domain to stress test
novel methods so there's a large history
of computational and quantitative
methods in genetics the data is at a
scale where you know it's not obscenely
large but it's large and interesting and
and so it's to my mind just a great way
you know playground to develop novel
methods that will be useful in practice
and the way I try and formulate a
problem when we do these things is you
know even if I actually sort of find the
you know the underlying scientific
questions interesting I try and ask the
geneticist you know why should I care
kua methods person and one answer to
that is you know if you can if the
method we develop applies to some other
area mass spec imaging or or cosmology
or climate science with you know
relatively minor tweaks not totally
redoing everything in a siloed way
that's interesting because then I can go
back to the methods people and I can say
what we have
here is a new type of technique that is
is undervalued by the internet social
media metrics but that clearly is
something that should be at foundations
of data and it comes from this you know
these areas and in science and
biomedicine so one of these plots that
is just a great thing to know right
there's a lot of genetic diversity in
Africa and then there's a founder effect
and people come out and then the rest of
the world is just a small subset of the
diversity of sub-saharan Africa and so
people know this from not data analysis
techniques right I mean there's a large
body of knowledge to justify this some
of the snip technology I think you know
justified certain more low level aspects
of this understanding and we'll get but
but I wanted to mention this because
I'll show you a picture in a few slides
and and the picture I show you is that
interesting or not that's the question
to that so the particular data is that
we look at here this was stuff it you
know on the size scale it's 2,000 by 1/2
million so it's large but not obscenely
large but you know whereas if if you're
just interested in scaling and so on you
know it's not worth worrying about you
know it's not like you run one
computation of PCA or SVG or whatever
you gonna let you do that you realize
you made a mistake you go back you mean
Center something now you do it a
thousand times as part of a
cross-validation you know etc etc
there's a whole pipeline there that that
you do and so you know how do you
evaluate this by statistical or computer
scientific metrics so that's a
challenging thing because it's not just
raw CPU time if you're doing large-scale
simulations you know raw CPU time is a
proxy for how well it performs but for
these more machine learning and data
analysis methods is actually actually a
very poor proxy because the whole
pipeline is what matters and so a lot of
the sub buzz and data science and
engineering social media applications
has to do with you know getting an
ecosystem where it becomes easier to do
things even if they're factor or to
slower this raw compute time so the
method we want to use here is something
called a singular value decomposition
and or PCA and to first sort of think of
them as the same if you don't know them
so the SVD is is just a it's a
structural fact about Hilbert spaces or
Euclidean spaces and the way in
manifests
on a wide wide range of data
applications is via something called PCA
PCA is a technique to find you know
vectors in in a Euclidean space that are
sort of capture the variance and the
data and are perpendicular to each other
and so Euclidean space a special case of
that is this is just a plane you know
and I have here a picture of the plane
and I have 20 points or so on the plane
and if I was to say to you you can
choose one line on that plane to capture
the most of the data you know and and
I'm not gonna tell you any labels I'm
not gonna tell you just one line you
can't use the whole plane as one line
and capture most information about the
data and I'm not gonna let you define
information I'm not gonna be a method a
lot be pedantic method a lot it just
just give me one line what are you gonna
choose and you know you'll probably
choose that line as opposed to a line
rotated by 45 degrees or 90 degrees and
sort of why that line and and basically
it's because it maximizes the variance
right so you notice neither of these
zero is not on any of these axes so we
had invent empliciti mean center so mean
center etc etc and if you do that this
is the line that maximizes variance the
terms linear algebra is a subspace and
so this is the first singular vector the
first principal component and the second
one is the vector the direction that
captures the most variants conditioned
on being perpendicular to the first so
you remove you put you you remove the
first direction and you ask on the
subspace what's the direction of maximum
variance and on the plane there's only
two vectors and you can have that are
perpendicular to each other in n
dimensional spaces you can get n of them
and so PCA iterates this process to do
it n times so those are singular vectors
and singular values are these numbers
Sigma that captures sort of the length
of these vectors uni the amount of
variability and the idea is that if
Sigma one is much larger than Sigma 2
and and you can only keep one line on
one axis you should probably keep Sigma
1 now I could give you adversary
constructed data where that's not so
interesting right if if you measured
stuff and the dominant effect is a day
of the week effect or the dominant
effect is the mean because they haven't
mean sent it for the dominant effect is
something else then the first singular
vector is going to capture that as a
methods person
my problem right that I have succeeded
at capturing the big most variance on
the appliance side you're gonna say well
that's not so useful because that
variance isn't tell me something so you
know whose job is it to fix that right
is the job of the pre-processing of the
data or the job of the method and and
you know now York involving those two
lines but what we'll be talking about
today let's the method will apply to
either of those but that's something to
keep in mind cuz a lot of things go by
the name PCA robust pca which aren't pca
from this perspective but our variance
on this that involved those lines so the
formal definition of an SVD is you have
a matrix a and i want to decompose it
into three matrices and our floral
transformation a diagonal the scaling
and another orthogonal transformation
and then the idea here is that the sigma
the middle matrix is diagonal and and
they're all positive or non-negative and
and so there's the largest as the second
largest as a third largest and at some
point you say the top 10 22 3 whatever
are significant and the rest are noise
and that's a modelling decision right
it's a wide B's choose 10 or 20 and
that's something that if I'm a computer
scientist I don't care about right
that's that's the job of a Smet machine
learn or a statistician to choose that
model selection some things might be
much more significant on the genetics
side and when I say significant I mean
not in a significance testing sense and
not in a you know that's sent but but in
the sense that it's it captures some
sort of signal and the rest will model
is noise and you know clearly that's
imperfect there may be some signal
burden noise and vice-versa but you know
that's a first stab at capturing what's
going on and so you can imagine that
this matrix a is is ten thousands people
by a million snips and I might try and
project it onto two or three or four
dimensions and I say what do I gain and
what do I lose by that and you might
guess that you gain very coarse
information you know you can reproduce
very coarse information but but you lose
finer scale information and that's the
case and so you typically want to
compute the SVD such as you keep the
significant things and remove the noise
and so this is this I'm gonna show some
results in genetics but you know we and
others I mean this is if this is a very
hello world sort of technique to use and
so the techniques I'll be describing
here we've we have applied to genetics
and mass spec imaging so it's a basic
methodological question that we've
applied to all these sort of
and it grew out of randomized linear
house with that first anecdote I had a
little bit while back so let's say we
have the matrix it's I think the
particular results we had were 2,000 by
500,000 but you can apply to others we
have but the particular results are
showing the second do that and let's say
that we mean centered correctly and
we've removed a day of the week effect
we've removed all these things and and
then we plot it in two dimensions and
what you see is if you plot it you get
this so let's take a look at this for a
second so this is either interesting or
trivial again depending on sort of what
you your perspective so take a look at
this for a second so we're plotting
every data point on top two eigenvectors
and so there's Africa and Middle Eastern
Europe and East Asia and America is and
then the Mexicans are stuck in the
middle I mean what are they doing there
so what are we looking at and what's
going on
the Mexicans seem out of place this sort
of looks like it's visual support for
the Out of Africa hypothesis but you
know the Mexicans what are they doing
there and is this a success or a failure
right it looks like something Goods
going on we're getting some clustering
the way we might expect and color coded
according to the labels and though
whether people are from some people seem
to cluster together that makes sense
sound don't and what we're looking at
here is an artifact of the fact that the
world you view if you look at a slide
deck on the wall is two-dimensional
right if you plot and set on the top
three components you'll see this out of
Africa Middle East Europe Oceania East
Asians and then American meaning Native
American Indians pop out in the third
eigen direction and Mexicans interpolate
between Europe and America which of
course makes a lot of sense given you
know what's known historically about it
mixing and so on so on the one hand this
is a success right it's visual
supportive out of Africa I think things
cluster the way they'd work any
foundations any methods person would say
this is fabulous see it works and if you
take your your method and you apply it
to Twitter data in term document data
and natural language processing data and
so on then you get a result is clean you
declare success and you're done right
you show this to a geneticist so they'll
say yeah we know that and so there's a
couple things that a little
dissatisfying about this one is the yeah
yeah we know that
already so you know if you're generating
this gobs of data and you you know you
knew the first sort of the Out of Africa
hypothesis without this data and we're
trying to ask more refined questions
does all this data and anything to that
discussion or not the other thing is you
know there's a computational question
can you find these things efficiently
I'll get to that a second but also this
one is a little bit more subtle and it's
important you know in terms of how
scientific and other biomedical is
relate to foundations and you know what
are these eigenvectors and we're doing
pca or SVD but if you use something
called the support vector machine or
logistic regression or any of a wide
range of other techniques you do
something like this and and what this is
is you're taking you're taking advantage
of the fact that you're modeling the
data as a vector and you're thinking
about the data in terms of Euclidean
space you so you're taking linear
combinations and so the data are linear
combinations of the eigenvectors of
linear combinations of the data so these
are eigen snips or eigen people that
you're viewing the top two eigenvectors
are eigen people or eigen snips and so
there's two sort of issues one is
computing large SPD's takes a footprint
of time at the scale we're looking at it
took 20 minutes we have to do a thousand
of those as a part of a cross-validation
and so that you know it starts to add up
especially when you get larger the other
is we want might want to select actual
snips that capture the structure of the
top principal components and this is
this is intractable basically you know
if for any notion the best but if you
relax this to say I want you know not to
get the top let's say K principal
components where K is some parameter but
the top k plus 10 and I want to be
epsilon close to the best you can't
solve that and you can solve that with
random projections so these are two
complementary issues that arise in a lot
of applications and the latter just
isn't on the radar of a lot of machine
learners because you're using your
methods and you're justifying it not
within sight both prediction quality and
in a lot of scientific cases you want to
get some sort of qualitative insight you
want to be able to go to the practicing
geneticist say you know we we got these
snitches these are the important ones
and they look at and say yeah that makes
sense that's in the middle of a coding
and so a solution to this and I think
it's the next two slides yeah that you
know is I calling it see you are
sometimes called CSS P column
subset selection problems and so the
goal is the following so this was summer
when we wrote this up for PNAS and you
can imagine we had a terrible time
getting a methods paper into PNAS but
that succeeded and so that's the first
reference there about ten years ago
while very efficient basis vectors
mathematically abstractly the singular
vectors themselves are completely
artificial and do not correspond to any
actual DNA expression profiles and ditto
if you do climate science and mass spec
or anything else you will be interesting
to find basis vectors basis in a linear
algebraic sense I'm using actual
experimental vectors and not artificial
bases that offer linear that offer
little insight so these aren't the
artificial vectors they're well-defined
mathematical things but but but they're
not meaningful in terms of the data and
so the answer is yes so given a black
box I won't describe you can get a small
number of actual columns and rows that
are only marginally worse than SVD and
so that is this column subset selection
and it's very robust to heuristic
modification so there's a theory aspect
to this there's a there's an applied
aspect to this but it is but it's very
robust in that sense and so you can use
the same methods to approximate PCA and
SVD and under the hood here is a random
projection so you can implement these
things on terabytes of data so we have a
system to do that and so this is the tip
of an iceberg and randomized numerical
linear algebra which is the first
anecdote that I described which is a
central discipline area that research
that exploits randomization as a
resource to develop improved algorithms
for all sorts of large-scale problems
that are in particular data that are
modeled by linear algebra and so you can
evaluate this as a methods person and
that's interesting from a theoretical
computer science and theoretical
statistics you can evaluate this in
terms of applications scientific or
non-scientific and it's people are
interested in both and you can evaluate
this in terms of implementations you
know you implement this on AWS on a
supercomputer on one machine and it's
interesting because this navigates the
space between those three and sort of a
very it's a treacherous space but it
navigates it very well so I think it can
be a model for how to do foundational
work that's sort of interesting on the
foundation side but also on the applied
side and this is a picture you know from
something we took in and the sniffs by
chromosomal order what we're what we're
planning is is something that's under
the hood in this algorithm which is sort
of a an importance metric which
the central to a lot of the foundations
but correlated very strongly with in it
with with with you know metrics people
use in in in genetics having to do with
you know essentially in influence
measures and it's not the case that this
these PCA scores are flat if the data
was Gaussian and so on that it'll be
flat so you know it's important on the
algorithm side to take advantage of not
that and so it has strong connections
here with regression Diagnostics in a
lot of other areas that that um you want
to find some outlying things and that's
when you find it if you describe with
this to a statistician then say you want
to find the outliers and throw them out
if you describe this to a computer
scientist they'll say you know the data
is all that I have in front of me so I
should go I'm on to the outliers because
those are the most important things and
if you talk to the geneticists you know
there's no snips or snaps right there's
no Gaussian assumption here each is a
singular event in human history and so
these outlying things may very well be
the most important thing so let me wrap
up and to wrap up you know I wanted to
talk about just much and something I
mean some people you think of this data
stuff I think if you're do biomedicine
you think of this data stuff anything
you know there's it's reminiscent of
bioinformatics you know is this all
that's going on isn't the same thing and
I think I think it's actually very
different and it's worth thinking about
the differences because if biomedicine
is going to meet foundations partway and
influence foundations you need to engage
in very different ways than happened
with bioinformatics so you know how did
or does bioinformatics relate to
computer science and statistics and
applied mathematics and that's a
technical question so I tried to allude
to some of the technical questions in
terms of but also sort of sociologically
and so you know if you have a methods
graduate student you know are they gonna
get can they do something on internet
and social media and bio data or do they
need to decide on day one that they're
gonna go one route or the other which
case you can imagine which way they go
sort of how did NIH choose to fund
graduate students and postdocs in the
budget expansion of the 90s I mean so
here you had a situation where the
budget of the NIH doubled and what
effect did that have on the number of
American citizens going into biomedical
research
you say you throw more money at
something you think something goes up
and did it go up or is it different
because of the way the funds are
funneled but you know by senior into
senior pis and the average age of a
first-time ro1 is you know going up and
up and and so if that's the case then
you're gonna have a selection biased
against people who potentially have
options to go off and do other things in
data science maybe and how does the pay
structure biomedical research engage in
these you know these questions if if the
pay structure is held to artificially
low or high you know whatever there's
gonna be a lot of people who just say
I'm gonna go elsewhere where the
pastures are greener and that is a look
locally rational decision and it may
have negative consequences more
generally and so this is a question
about how NIH Vixen do they you know the
US taxpayer sort of questions at a large
scale but when the rubber hits the road
you know I'm a PI I'm a graduate student
I'm something you know where's the
where's the pastures greener and and if
the greener I'm gonna go there that's
that's the forcing function what effect
is a Medical School deciding not to hire
joint faculty OCS departments have on
bioinformatics and big biomedical data
so I gave a version of this talk at
Stanford Medical School's I had the
slide there with them couple years ago
and I mean I said it in the middle of
the method space and there's these it's
always tricky to get hired between
staffs and computer science because one
has more money and it's stronger and so
on and I I mean I can point you to
several examples where you know a medic
the computer science department comes
from med school says why don't we do
this joint higher and the med school
basically says here get out of here we
don't want to deal with the Provost and
we'll just do it ourselves if we want to
and and and the same thing happens you
know in between stats and CS and so I
mean at different universities and so
that's maybe a rational decision for the
Medical School because you don't want to
deal with the Provost but you know what
effect does that have on this sort of
interdisciplinary interaction and so on
so I think it's worth thinking through
these things but I think it's actually
very different the bioinformatics and if
you adopt the same MO in terms of
bioinformatics there's an opportunity
loss so I think take a step back and I
think the high level bit is just
consider the creation of big things you
know molecular biology biotechnology and
the range of other areas these were
driven by new measurement techniques and
they led to big academic questions new
perspective on the worlds how are
thinking of things and so there's a lot
of weed level questions as the stuff
evolves and and so I think we're in the
middle of a similarly big shift I think
that data that arises in biomedical and
other sort of scientific applications
has a lot to say here but this challenge
isn't getting and integrated so I'll
leave it at that and what if anything
does biomedicine have to offer great
thank you so much for this talk Michael
it's it's been both insightful and it's
given this a lot of food for thought
we're already at the top of the hour so
I think we're out of time for questions
and I think we'll end it here thank you
again thank you all right thanks a lot